So far we've talked mostly about the role of
Health Informatics to improve the delivery of care.
What about its role in ensuring we deliver the right care to every patient, every time?
This is a major concern of the Academy of Medicine,
which is the new name for the Institute of Medicine.
It recognizes that we are entering a new era of
medical science that offers the prospect of personalized health care.
It also recognizes that physicians and patients must deal with
an increasingly complex array of health care options and decisions,
and they need help to choose wisely.
That help in turn,
may require new knowledge about what works and when and for whom it works.
To achieve that, years ago IOM called for a learning health care system.
That it describes as a sustainable system that gets
the right care for people when they need it
and then captures the results for further improvement.
In simple terms, we need to gather data from care already delivered,
aggregated, and analyze it to learn from
the collective results of many care representatives.
We need a feedback cycle.